let's go next to
dave from is it heldsberg i can't quite
see
it's hildsberg sir thank you so much i'm
honored to speak to a freaking predator
heal yes thank you he'll hold on i have
that drop that is a freaking predator
where is healdsburg
hillsborough is in sonoma county just
north of san francisco about 75 miles
beautiful area
yeah i'm currently standing in a
vineyard it's uh it's a wonderful life i
gotta get back i've been to a bunch of
the vineyards there and it is just great
there's this i believe in uh where i
believe in downtown napa there's like a
high-end food court called the uh oh man
i don't even remember it's just it's
just a great area
i very much uh enjoy it myself i've been
here my whole life so well what's on
your mind for a living
i don't want to talk about joe rogan as
well okay everybody
little context i started with joe rogan
at episode 36 in june of 2010
i never missed an episode until october
2020 when i couldn't take it anymore
the covidiency
and
the things that he was saying about
politics in general fashion on biden
uh seemingly ignoring all the problems
with trump
uh i more or less gave it up but i've
gone back to listening when the pandemic
uh
is out and i think people are
missing some significant things here the
audience of joe rogan
they don't care about fact checkers
they don't care what the mainstream
media says
and the more they attack him the more
they're going to run to him yes if it's
any chance at coast course correction
somebody needs to go on the rogan
podcast and talk him out of
the bad ideas that he has
clung on to um
and i don't know who that person is
wondering if you have any ideas no i
don't i mean i don't know that there's
any one person who can talk him out of
everything i think it's you know with
rogan it's a lot of
he'll he'll listen to anybody he has on
the the challenge is getting the right
people on and i'd be glad to be on any
time with him i'm not an expert in a lot
of the areas in which he's allowed
incorrect information to fester i'm
aware of the fact that the information
is wrong but i'm i'm not an expert in
that but i i don't think there is any
one person i think it would take sort of
like a concerted effort of bringing on
different types of guests for an
extended period of time quite frankly
yeah i mean i think what you could do is
point out to him that he's far too
inclined to accept a person's supposed
qualifications
i mean even in his apology
when he came on the first time um
through the video
he immediately threw out
the qualifications of mccola and malone
as well that alone makes anything that
they say true yes which is just
absolutely wrong and then of course um
when it came to
the the apology for the the n-word video
the a previous caller just got it wrong
i i don't think spotify took those down
i think rogan took them down i think
he got tired of having
those out there
out of thousands of episodes what's it
matter if there's 110 it only benefited
him as well because now people think
he's under attack and people are taking
his his episodes now i mean
the thing the statement was that spotify
has taken them down what you're
suggesting is that what's been reported
isn't true which is possible but i think
it's meant it we should be clear that
this is just your
opinion yeah and that's based on what he
said in his uh in his apology video for
that um i just i think it's uh
it's far more likely that he didn't want
it out there anymore because he saw
himself in the video and like he said it
made him stick to to his stomach just to
see himself saying those things so no
harm in taking them down when there's
thousands of episodes it's not like
anybody was going to go listen i mean
that's the thing with mikola and
malone's episodes too put fact checks on
them take them down censor them it
doesn't matter that information's
already out there yeah at this point
the rogan mantra of uh the only thing to
do with bad speech is to combat it with
good speech is the only strategy that
work going forward somebody has to go on
and talk in some of those ideas david
i'm a huge fan i have been for a long
time member and uh this has been an
absolute pleasure thank you all right
thanks dave appreciate uh appreciate
your your support and uh as a member
dave gets access to the much derided
bonus show oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad